[Applause]
foreign
hi everyone
secure thank you so much for joining us
now there are first of all we need to
address because there are media reports
of a major incident in Nottingham
yeah I people here will probably be
seeing the news filtering through and I
don't think we can start this session
without acknowledging that there has
been a serious incident in Nottingham
this morning
information is still coming through but
it's just been reported that three
people have lost their lives so I'm sure
I speak for everybody in this room in
saying that we'd like to just send our
thoughts to all those affected and to
the emergency services who are
responding to this as we speak so I
think we will get to Tech obviously in
just a moment but I just think when
there's something that serious happening
in Nottingham we just need to
acknowledge it as I say send our
thoughts to those that are affected and
thank those that are responding to it on
behalf of all of us yeah and secure
before we get on to Tech actually and AI
it's been quite a weekend for UK
politics it has been quite a weekend for
everybody following
um
so on Friday night I was doing a speech
for Margaret Beckett who's one of our
longest standing MPS she's been an MP
for 49 years and I was in Derby
with about 550 people thanking her for
her service and as I sat down I got a
note put in front of me that said Boris
Johnson has resigned with immediate
effect
and then on Sunday I went for lunch it
was my wife's birthday went for lunch
with a number of friends and just as we
were sitting down I saw my phone ping up
that Nicholas sturgeon had been arrested
so that's quite a lot to pack in to one
weekend and obviously it comes on the
back of a very turbulent 12 months or so
this time last year Boris Johnson was
prime minister we've burnt through three
prime ministers we've had four
chancellors and four budgets in the last
12 months and you know politically
that makes for a lot of material
um it is certainly
evidence of chaos at a party political
parties usually fight like this when
they're out of office it's very unusual
to have it when they're in office and
now we've got three by-elections caused
by just political Fallout
um often you have by-elections because
someone sadly dies or is very ill or
there's some finding against them to
have three by-elections which are
essentially political Tantrums is really
unprecedented and you know politically
obviously from our point of view
um you know we look at it and see that
chaos but there is a price to be paid
and
everywhere you go across the country
most people are really worried about the
cost of living they're worried about how
they're going to pay their bills and for
them to see a government squabbling with
itself instead of focusing on what they
need addressed I think is you know a
very serious situation for this
government to have got itself into and
there's a deeper price because there's a
reputational hit to the UK and I think
there's an economic hit as well because
many investors so this is very relevant
to what we're discussing this morning
many investors say to me we're not
investing in the UK right now because we
don't see the conditions of certainty
and stability that we need in order to
invest and that will infect people in
this room it'll affect startups
businesses not only in Tech but across
many many sectors so there's a political
price of this chaos as well but with the
implosion of the s p do you see what
kind of opportunity do you see for labor
in Scotland well the implies of the sap
has been very profound
um and uh
I think it's done two things
it's now allowed a proper examination of
the SNP record in government until this
point the s p was
um quite able to ensure that the only
discussion in Scotland was about
independence about the referendum
constitutional issues and not about the
things that actually in many respects
matter
um so much more to people so now that
torch if you like that light is shown on
their record and it's not a very good
record from our point of view it
obviously gives us an opportunity to
make an argument about Scotland about
the future of Scotland
um that you know
means we are more likely to be heard as
we go forward we've got a strong case to
put in Scotland a very positive case to
put in Scotland it doesn't necessarily
flow that because the SMP implodes SNP
voters necessarily move to a different
political party we've got to earn every
vote we've got to make our case but
we've now got the chance to make that
case so we're at London take with yeah
you look at AI is it a risk or a benefit
it I mean a bit of both they're a huge
potential and everybody in this room
knows that and
um
incredible opportunities I did a speech
on the future of the NHS a few weeks ago
and my main thesis was the nhs's
face down on the floor it needs to be
back up on its feet
but more than that it needs to be fit
for the future which is a different
question part of making it fit for the
future is using technology to a much
greater extent it's an important report
come out this morning on that and one of
the examples I used in my speech which
is about AI was if a radiologist works
with AI when doing scans for cancer
particularly liver scans they're 60 more
likely to get them at an earlier stage
which makes a massive difference
obviously to the individual patient and
a huge difference to the NHS as well so
huge huge potential but of course risks
risks of misinformation risks that it's
used in ways which we wouldn't consider
to be good risks more broadly that AI is
accelerating so very fast that some of
the jobs that are being done now by
people will almost certainly be being
done by AI already are to some extent
but I'm really struck by the speed of
acceleration of development in AI and so
we need to put ourselves in a position
to take advantage of the great benefits
but guard against the risks do you use
Church GPT and if so would you ask it
well so I
I have a master class on chat GPT
um almost every day because I've got a
14 year old son
um who looks at it all the time and
shows me what it's capable of and it's
really incredible on a number of
respects one that for my 14 year old son
this is not seen to be outlandish it's
something which he thinks is really
interesting will be a major part of his
life so I see it developing
um there see what it's capable of doing
see what he puts into it and information
that you can get out of it at the drop
of a hat absolutely incredible you only
have to see that to realize the impact
it's going to have on jobs
I've also had I was talked through the
example of the radiologist and AI at a
cancer Round Table to see to understand
myself how that works but it comes up
all the time a week ago Monday I was at
Hinckley Point C the nuclear reactor
that is being built it's Somerset and
they've they've got 9 000 people on that
site in the construction site and they
have to but it's a massive site biggest
construction site I think in Europe have
to bust them around the site the whole
time and already the question is is AI
going to be driving used to drive the
buses and therefore what's the impact
for jobs so it's all around us
um I feel we're slightly behind the
curve I think the government's right to
focus on AI but there's a long way to go
in terms of what we do with it
regulation we're just beginning to have
the discussion that's needed both here
and internationally and a much more
informed discussion about jobs I think
is vitally vitally important because
otherwise
you know we we will risk not addressing
one of the key questions which is who
benefits from this
um who benefits is it just those that
always benefit from advancements in
technology or is it everybody that we
take with us and it's got to be the
second of those how many jobs do you
think
really wiped out so how do you protect
those jobs I I look I don't know the
number as the honest answer I'm not sure
anybody really does but the percentages
that have been put out there are quite
staggering and you can see why because
um AI is now moving so fast capable of
doing things drafting contracts writing
documents assessing Financial material
um you know helping with driving buses
Radiologists scanning so it is obvious
it'll have an impact the question is how
do we harness that good and this is
where I think there's a real point of
Distinction so
do we agree with the government the AI
is really important yes do I think it's
right that Russia sunak has set up a
summit
um here later in the year yes but what's
the substance and how do you I mean this
is being developed predominantly by the
private sector at speed you know we've
got an advantage Google deepmind is here
we've got brilliant Innovation we've got
brilliant universities
um so we've got all the attributes if
you like to make a real success of this
but we're nowhere near where we need to
be on the question of Regulation there's
a bit of piecemeal sector by sector
regulation you know in the medical field
the legal field Etc financial services
but we haven't got an overarching
framework
um and so we've got to get our hands
around this we do need to be clear about
what we're doing about jobs and then
there's a mindset an incoming labor
government
will be a government that partners with
business
with a clear long-term strategy
a skill strategy
and an industrial structure that means
that we work together with business so
we will be a government that rolls up
its sleeves gets on the pitch and works
with business to make sure that we
harness the great benefits of AI and
together work against the risk and most
businesses I've spoken to in relation to
AI say look here it would be a good
thing to have regulation because we
think that that will make it more likely
that we can succeed so I think that
working in this way we can make a real
success of this the risk is in a way
that we don't take that opportunity so
concretely what does it look like like
an AI Ministry
oh I I think there's going to have to be
an overarching regulatory framework of
some sort
um the government's talking about
principles in legislation which then
find themselves in each of these sectors
I think we can have something stronger
than that I think Foundation AI needs
regulation as well and that requires
International Leadership as well as
leadership
um here but also working with businesses
because you need a government that's on
the pitch working with business to say
if there are to be changes in jobs let's
say there are job losses what are we
going to do about the workforce what's
the Skilling reskilling agenda and how
does that work at PACE as we go forward
and that's something which has not
happened now for many years so does AI
mean we should seriously consider
Universal basic
well I'm not attracted to Universal
basic income I think that the advantage
here would be for AI to take some of the
jobs
that AI will be able to do and for us to
make sure that we can train and retrain
and reskill the workforce into other
areas but that so that's where I would
put my um energy and I think there's a
almost every business I speak to says to
me almost all the time I haven't got the
skills I need and therefore there's a
huge huge opportunity here to get this
um right the apprenticeship Levy um is
constantly complained about and ought to
be changed so there's stuff we can do
there we've proposed skills England
which is a body to oversee skills and I
want to devolve skills also closer to
where businesses are in their area
geographically so I think we need to
seize the skills agenda and see that so
I wouldn't go down the Ubi route I would
go down the skills and re-skilling Route
but how difficult is that given we don't
really know the jobs of tomorrow I mean
I should have asked chat at gbt what
they see as as the skills needed you
could have got the answers
we have to ask your son to do
yeah but I mean I I think rather than
sit and try to identify each and every
job that might be affected and there's
going to be many I think it's a sense of
what's the infrastructure the framework
that a government needs to set up and
are we ready for the speed of this
because I think there's still a bit of a
feeling that AI may affect us in five
years or six or seven years I think it's
more likely to be in the next 12 months
18 months so we've got a plan for you
know rapid change and at the moment
under this government we don't have that
infrastructure that framework in place
so what does that look like for r d
funding if you look at r d funding
smaller if you take government business
or city I think it's less than Google
and apple between them I think Google
and apple put in more in r d than the
government does
and that's
similar in other countries if I'm right
so that's not
peculia to the UK and I think it's
probably wrong to just think well this
should be a competition with each side
sort of upping the numbers I think it's
how we work together this is why
um the partnership model that we want in
government is vitally important
I mean assuming
um we have an election next year which
obviously we we will have
we get the opportunity
um and it is an opportunity
um if we get the privilege to serve but
we're going to inherit a real mess the
economy has broken public services are
broken
um the civil service is lost
um it's sort of
um confidence in the light of constant
attacks so we've got to pick the country
up and our reputation isn't where it
should be we'll pick the country up and
what I've said is that requires us to be
Mission driven to be absolutely clear
what are we going to achieve in
government and we've got five clear
missions the first of which is economic
growth and how do we achieve that and
Technology AI will be part of the story
whether it's on health whether it's
growing the economy that will enhance
and allow us to drive forward with those
missions which and they will require us
to partner with business if you win an
election I think you can legitimately
say this is what we will achieve in
government we've set it out but then you
get the choice of saying well how will
you do that will you suck it up to
Westminster Whitehall and do it from the
center no I don't don't think that model
Works will you simply say well we've set
out what we want to achieve it's for the
um for the market now to determine how
that's done I don't think that model
works and not many businesses believe
that's the model that's going to work or
do you say we're going to have a true
partnership between an active agile
labor government and business clear
about what we're trying to achieve and
working together to achieve it and
therefore when it comes to r d the
question is how do we jointly make the
best of R D which we desperately need to
do the UK does have
Farm but they've listed in New York so
how do you make it attractive for a
business like that to to list here well
look I do think that we I mean we're
third in the world
um and we've got
um amazing Tech going on in the UK we
need to recognize that we need to be
clear about that and make sure that we
don't lose that
um Google deepmind is fantastic it's in
my constituency
um I've seen it a number of times and as
many people here will have done we've
got brilliant universities we've got
startups Galore that are you know using
Tech the whole time in order to harness
that we've got to have not just the
skills that I was speaking about got to
help in the the problem with startups is
that when they scale up it tends to go
elsewhere so we've got to capture that
problem which is about access to Capital
and create the environment where we can
succeed on this I genuinely think we can
do it but it is about creating the
environment to do it so do you think
under a labor government a lot of
entrepreneurs and investors here will
want to stay in the UK and also list in
the UK yeah I hope so because we want to
create the environment which it will be
possible to start up to scale up where
we can attract the sorts of innovation
technical Innovation and build on what
we've got but the single most important
thing is going to be growing the economy
we've had a pretty stagnant economy for
13 years now and we've got to kick start
that and get the growth that we need and
that requires a long-term plan for
growth I mean it goes back to almost
where we started
um for growth in this country the the
foundational stone is stability and
certainty
um and that's what we've been lacking
under this government we've been
chopping it's politically amusing that
we've had three prime ministers in a
year when it comes to Growing the
economy and investing uh is hopeless it
puts people off investing it creates the
sense this isn't an environment where we
can be sure what's even going to happen
for the next six months if your business
secretary changes all the time then you
can't make key decisions so stability
long-term strategic thinking that's why
I want missions by the way which is to
answer the question what's the five or
even 10-year strategy for this
government so everybody in this room
everybody listening to this knows right
that's where they're going to put their
attention that's the focus they've got
and we can make investment and other
decisions based on that degree of
certainty but how much of your attention
would you focus on for example chip
manufacturing if you look at Nvidia that
makes chips for you know AI they became
a one trillion million dollar company
yeah look we could do we do have
expertise in some areas here but
obviously we've got to get the
relationship with the U.S riot in
relation to chips so there's that
International heavy
duty pulling as well and that is another
area that I'm worried about because I
think
the turmoil we've had the chaos in
government
does affect how other countries look at
us I went to Davos earlier this year and
one of the big takeaways for me was
other countries lamenting the fact that
the UK is not on the international stage
in the way that it used to be and I want
that wanted there and and here to have a
statement of intent which is an incoming
labor government will put us right back
on the international stage and leading
on some of the discussions that will
have a profound impact on growth
stability what's our response the
inflation reduction act in America was a
critical question I can feel investors
being drawn towards the US a winning
response in the UK to that we can't just
sit it out saying well we don't really
agree with what they're doing so we'll
look on and do nothing I think that's
completely wrong so creating those
conditions for businesses to thrive is
absolutely vital to us but is that with
subsidies and Frank with what money well
we've got a what we call a green
Prosperity plan which is a plan which
sets out
what we intend to achieve one example of
that for example is green power a clean
power generation by 2030 that's a
stretch Target
um I think it could be done with
technology with AI running towards the
problem it'll give us lower bills
security independence from tyrants like
Putin and a real chance to grow our
economy and we need money put behind
that but it's also about the partnership
working so we've got a plan that will
you know be our equivalent if you like
of the inflation reduction act what I
don't believe in is a government that
just looks at the problem then sits it
out I think it'd be a huge mistake for
our country we've got to be on the pitch
agile and active working with business
to reap will be the very great rewards
if we get this right this has the
potential to be the sort of next
generation of job skill jobs in place
across the country all bundled up
together that's a huge huge prize that
we need to go out there and seize so we
talked a bit about the opportunities
very quickly as we end up are we in a AI
Terminator 2 situation what are you most
afraid of when it comes to Ai and
Technology firstly I don't want to just
get into the business of saying I'm
afraid of it all because actually I do
think it's got brilliant potential
um obviously misinformation is a problem
and if it gets to a stage where people
don't trust the information they've got
um I think is a real issue I do think
that we need to fast forward on the
regulation side
um I don't see that going at anything
like the speed
um and you know I'm not in the sort of
you know existential question but I do
fit I mean because I I tend to sort of
be much more grounded than that I think
most people who are beginning to talk
about IA aai and understanding what it
means we'll probably be thinking what's
this mean for my job will I be all right
with my job what happens if AI does a
bit of my job and I won't just be
um some of the people have been most
affected by Tech in the past it will be
I think at all levels I I could see in
the legal profession I mean obviously I
was a lawyer before I became a
politician I've seen the legal
profession question the AI could have a
profound impact on drafting of contracts
um you know the sorts of things that
routinely a lawyer might do and so we've
got to answer that question about what's
our answer to people say I want a
skilled secure job of the future which
is totally understandable I know it's
going to be affected by AI what's my
government doing working with the sector
to ensure that my future is secure and
that I benefit along with everybody else
in something that could and I'm sure
will be you know a real game changer for
the country secure starmer thank you so
much for your time thank you so much
thank you for having me
[Applause]
well thank you very much to secure
starma it's great to hear how policy
makers are grappling with the
significance of AI
um
Terminator 2 or not I think it's really
Testament to everyone here in this room
and to the tech sector that we've had so
many high-profile politicians on stage
this week it really shows just that how
how importantly and how seriously people
are taking the tech sector not just
businesses but as a way of